this
is star talk cosmic queries edition we
could not resist
the nobel prizes in physics are related
to black holes
chuck yes we're devoting this entire
cosmic queries
to black holes as manifested in the
recently announced nobel prizes in
physics
and the cool thing about it is no one
will ever be able to see
or hear this video because it won't be
able to escape
our black hole oh is that right i didn't
know
that all of our shows are in black holes
just this one i know a little bit about
black holes but not as much as
our guest a recurring guest janet levin
janna
welcome back to star talk thank you it's
always good to be here
wherever cuba is wherever here is now i
know but
for you you kind of look like you're in
a safe house i know
i sort of are you
in a identity protection program or
something what do you do
i'm at pioneer works which is you know a
cultural center in brooklyn where i'm
director of sciences but i tell you if
the apocalypse is happening this is
where i'm coming we've got all the
resources you need
wait wait chuck did you hear that she
said if the apocalypse was coming
that's where she'll be and that's where
she is now right exactly
you are invited
so wait tell me what happens at pioneer
works so we
uh this this place really started as an
inspiration of dustin yellen and gabriel
florence as an art center
but with a vision of just impacting
culture in creative ways really kind of
breaking down boundaries doing things in
a new way
and um and and when i came in we started
bringing sciences in here and we've been
doing a lot of um pretty incredible
science events
not least interviewing sir roger penrose
last december oh my gosh oh my god
that's why he got the nobel prize that's
why he got him
because you interviewed him i just like
rubbed my good karma on him
so so tell me so the uh i i know
two of the three nobel prize winners
maybe all three
so there's roger penrose a well-known uh
physicist from oxford i think
in the uk um we have uh who else was on
that list
andrea guezz uh andre gaz and is she
still in the university of california
yeah ucla
used to use ucla so and we had um
ryan gensler reinhard guenzo yeah rhino
genzel
and so these are so they all split the
nobel prize all for their work
in black holes so if you can just give
us sort of the
the the short version of each of theirs
contribution
to our understanding of black holes well
technically roger got half
the prize and andrea and reinhard split
the other half
so now when you say got half the prize
are we talking about the money
the money they have the money wow
after they each get they each get they
don't get a half a medal all right they
but when it's a half they mean half the
money yeah well you can let me tell you
something you can keep your stinking
metal
once you have them i want that check
it is it's a super interesting prize
because
that's happened before that where
they've divided the prize
unequally amongst the three participants
and you can never have more than three
winners of the nobel prize um so it is
uh it it does reflect the fact that
andrea
and reinhardt their work is
observational and they are
they're both responsible independently
for um understanding supermassive black
hole at the center of our galaxy
so that's why they shared in the prize
because they they both contributed to
that particular aspect of the award
roger penrose was just off on his own in
like 1964.
forever he's been doing he's on his own
right so there was all roger and he
um is very theoretical so i'd say one of
the most surprising things about this
award was that
people as theoretical as roger penrose
for example stephen hawking
don't usually get awarded the nobel
prize and
um and so this was considered i think a
lot of people were
were kind of chilled and delighted to
see sir roger
um honored in this way but it could be
that the trend is not so much that they
don't give it to theorists but if
they're going to give it to theorists
at in the same breath they're going to
give it to the experimentalist
who verified what the theorist said is
that a fair way to characterize it fair
way to characterize it
um but there's still a long stretch
between
like rogers theory and the observations
mm-hmm
so if you want to talk about roger wait
as was true with the higgs boson
that's right so they gave it to to peter
higgs
higgs himself yeah but he'd come up with
that decades ago yeah
whereas the fresh discovery of the higgs
boson was
recent in recent news but they staple
them together and then they give them
the award yeah
yeah that's right i mean hicks's
prediction was so very specific though
he literally predicted there were this
one particle
would be roughly around this mass and it
would
have these particular properties i mean
it is a pretty spot-on prediction
whereas roger just sort of was dreaming
big dreams
and not to put higgs down in any way but
you know there was a less specificity
and even when einstein got the nobel
prize he got it for very specific things
he did not get the nobel prize for
general relativity
which was clearly his greatest
achievement he got it for more specific
statements
and more specific specific predictions
so maybe the nobel committee is coming
along
yeah maybe it's coming along but yeah um
but roger did do something tremendous
which was
to make generic the prediction that
black holes
would be the end state of the collapse
of the star and
uh he was able to show that essentially
singularities which we
thought were this may be an artifact of
very special circumstances and wouldn't
really happen if you thought more
generally about things
he was able to prove that in fact it was
a generic prediction of general
relativity
that a collapsing star would create
behind it an event horizon
and interior would create a singularity
essentially
so it's right after einstein first
thinks of general relativity that
schwartshield writes to him from the
russian front
and discovers this thing that we now
call a black hole
but russian front in the first world war
in the first world war it's 1916
and he's on the russian front and he's
saying you know the world
the war the war has treated me kindly
enough and i've been able to wander
through the land of your ideas
and so here he solves this problem and
it's very idealized it's a complete
sphere
it's perfectly collapsed he doesn't ask
how or why he just
idealizes a situation and he comes up
with this thing that we now call a black
hole
and so for decades after that people
thought well that's just
a silly idealized situation it's not
wrong it's correct mathematically but
that'll never happen in nature
what roger penrose does in 1964 is he
uses the most ingenious methods
in a paper about three pages long and
the final paragraph of this incredibly
clear
lucid simple paper he proves that in
fact it is absolutely generic prediction
of general relativity that a collapsing
body
would create behind it an event horizon
and inside a singularity
so he makes black holes inevitable
he made them real made them real made
them real wow
yeah yeah so they go from this
mathematical perfect
silly platonic idealization to an
inevitable reality
so and now on the other side of that
nobel prize coin
we have two people independent
researchers who
are figuring out that our galaxy has a
supermassive black hole in the middle
but of course you can't see black holes
so what light can you shed on
on their discoveries you see what i did
there
your punster so they did
they they demonstrated the opposite
characteristics as
as as powerful scientists slow and
methodical
they looked at these stars for decades
right two decades
and they watched these stars orbit
um an invisible object and just they
don't even know
at the center of the galaxy at the
center of the galaxy it's 26 000 light
years away in the direction of the
constellation sagittarius
so we call the object that they orbit a
star sagittarius a star because only
because it's in that direction from our
point of view it's a cute little
nickname
so around sanjay star they see some
stars orbiting
and they can follow their entire orbits
take some one of them takes about 16 17
years
um that that's kind of the one that uh
was most helpful to them
but just to be clear normally when we
think of things orbiting other things we
think of planets orbiting stars
now you're talking about stars orbiting
other things yeah
exactly right exactly so now you have a
bunch of stars in the center of the
galaxy
a bunch that are orbiting this thing now
you can't see this thing
it's definitely dark and it's very
massive
and contrary i think to sort of the
popular imagination about black holes
black holes aren't huge the whole point
of alcohols is that they're tiny
so for how heavy they are they're tiny
so this
object they just look at the orbit and
deduce wow that thing is four million
times the mass of the sun
but it's fitting in a region much
smaller than the solar system
not four million times the size of the
sun right it's
if you calculate how big you think it
should be it's about 17
times the width of the sun across but
four
million times it's mass that's
crazy crazy crazy
so they go look it's really heavy it's
really small it's a super massive black
hole
wow okay well there you have it and by
the way this is our second or third hour
the astrophysics community our second or
third
nobel prize in a decade generally they
used to throw us a bone once again every
10 years
are you saying that you guys are the
meryl streep of the nobel prize i don't
know what i'm saying
black holes are well the prize is in the
category of physics just to be clear
so we in my community we're not living
our lives wondering if we'll be
considered
occasionally we do something that
touches on laws of physics and
and then it gets and people take a note
we just got it for
exoplanets which is not itself a new
branch of physics but it's a very
interesting
advance in our understanding of the
world and the universe
so i'm just saying maybe the we're done
with laboratories on earth
and the best laboratories on the
frontier of discovery are the universe
itself
well it's it's fascinating because
hubble
lobbied for astrophysics to be
considered by the physics novel
hubble the man edwin hubble the man
the telescope right is not live but it
tells kids it's not lobbying
that'd be cool that'd be awesome remains
inanimate yeah yes it remains it's still
it's still to this day
not a lot right but hubble really you
know so what did hubble do that was so
tremendous
today hubble up absolutely un
unquestionably would have won the nobel
prize so what are we doing
right so for one in the same decade yeah
he realizes that there are other
galaxies
you have to realize when einstein was
working in 1905 and 1950 and 1916
he did not know that there was another
galaxy besides the milky way
he suspected but he wasn't sure right
so hubble observes the first external
galaxies but just to be clear at that
time
the universe was just the stars of the
night sky yeah and how far do they
extend nobody knows
yeah yeah exactly and then the second
thing which i'm sure i'm
i'm guessing neil's referring to is he
then also notices
that oh by the way all those galaxies
are moving away from each other right
and and so he deduces that the universe
is expanding
so so he so he lobbied so he lobbied the
nobel committee and then what'd they say
i guess they said no
like well yeah i don't know if there
were like formal letters exchanged
but there was certainly political you
know there's internal politics
and they said no for one website 1920s
they said no for another 50 years i
don't think it was until the 70s that
the nobel prize committee considered
astrophysics yeah i think the first one
was maybe the discovery of pulsars
yeah and that was the 1970s on a
discovery made in the 60s yeah yeah
absolutely yeah yeah cool yeah well
actually we got to take a break now
but chuck did you load up questions
because this is a cosmic queries
i got them all loaded up and ready to go
and there are
pages of them people people love black
holes
all right when we come back more with
our friend jenna levin
to get us through an understanding of
black holes on star talk
we're back star talk cosmic queries
black hole edition
actually chuck we've had other black
hole editions of cosmic queries
but this time black hole's done one up
in one nobel prizes
in fact it's not the first time black
holes have won nobel prizes
and last time we did that we had to
bring in john 11 to explain what the
hell was going on
and we're doing that again today in this
second segment of cosmic queries
jenna always great to have you back in
the loop thank you so much i always love
being here
one of the times we brought you in was
because of the ligo discovery of
colliding black holes
right and they got a nobel prize okay so
black holes that so the
nobel committee is liking them some no
some black holes lately
yeah definitely i think there's probably
another one in the near future
um yeah i mean i don't want to you know
i don't want to i don't know jinx
don't keep us in suspense either well i
think
we should talk about lie though but i
think event horizon telescope
which took that image of the black hole
at the center of m87 which is a galaxy
55 million light years away
and they imaged as close to the event
horizon as is
essentially conceivable given the
realities of whatever but the resolution
was there
yes that's right yeah so for taking that
photo
the photo of a black hole okay it's
conceivable
so even so it's interesting if you look
at the nobel prize announcement for this
prize
they say about roger penrose for his
contribution to
understanding black holes and they
explicitly say that but for
angiogenesis and guenzel when they're
talking about the supermassive
black hole they don't name it they say
for their discoveries of a compact
object at the center of the galaxy
they won't call it a black hole yo let
me just say
that's racist yo that's some racist
stuff i've ever heard
all right that's all i'm saying
you are crazy that ain't right
if anything has a tinge of it chuck is
all up in it he's gonna be
gonna call it out okay thank you chuck
for calling out the racist ways
the nobel prize committee the
interesting reason why i suspect they
did that is because as so they're
looking at these orbits of these stars
right
around this dark object that we know is
really heavy and really small and by
rights we should call a black hole
but it only come it doesn't come near
the event horizon
doesn't come all the way close so it i
think the closest approach of the star
is about a few times as close as neptune
comes to the sun
and that's very very close when you're
talking about an object
uh four million times the mass of the
sun but if it's only 17 times as
wide it's not that close right you know
what i mean
whereas event horizon telescope is
seeing stuff like
right on it okay so chuck if they gave
it to the event horizon telescope and
still didn't call it a black hole then
you'll have that
then i got a cut then i got a case right
you got a case we'll take that to the
right we're going to take that okay cool
by the way one thing about the event
horizon telescope image
first of all a zillion people
participated in that so they probably
have to give
the nobel prize organizationally that's
a really interesting
yeah a question yeah it's a it's a
reminder that today
consortia make discoveries more so than
individuals
for ligo they gave it to three
individuals and because they were added
long but they've been they were having
long before ligo was even like exactly
they were at it for
for 30 40 years right right before other
people
joined and so that was different but
some people also argue that it should be
given a nobel
peace prize because here you have an
international consortium that transcends
you know all these nationalities all of
these political boards all these
languages all of these cultural
differences
and come together and then give the work
freely
then the work is free they don't even
monetize it right um
so that's an interesting article it's a
form of piece that's exactly right so
inside a form of piece that scientists
have known ever since the beginning
as collaborations take us international
yeah
a quick event horizon photo story before
we get to chuck's question
so i used the event horizon photo for a
tweet can i can i tell you what that
tweet was
it was okay so scientist colon
we've imaged a black hole in a galaxy
in the nucleus of a galaxy 55
million light years away public
scientists humans are causing global
warming public
i don't that doesn't agree with my
philosophy i don't agree with that
excellent how did that go down
down it was you know people
it's it's social media so it just goes
everywhere every which way but
everyone's awake
but the irony wasn't lost on most people
so it's nice that's brilliant that's a
brilliant tweet
yeah so so chuck so give it to me let's
get to it okay so
uh actually we're gonna start with the
patreon
question from uh my son because
i actually am on patreon so he gets to
ask
uh which is uh
can black holes tell us anything about
the age of nearby stars or stars that
are orbiting them
interesting am i trying it or are you
trying it yeah
i'll try and if i miss anything yeah
cause i think there's a lot of
dimensions to the end
so a black hole as the endpoint
of a star of a dead star that star
didn't live very long
you know maybe half a million years tops
so if you see a black hole if it's
freshly made
then the thing that made the black hole
itself was not all that old half a
million is not long in the history of
the universe not at all
so black holes are the product of very
high mass stars that have very short
lives
and but once you make the black hole
it's there right
so you'd have to have seen the black
hole get made to then know how young it
is
but if the black hole is just hanging
out um i don't know that you can know
how old it is
just by obser now now
we know there's an upper limit to how
massive a black hole can get
as the end point of a dying star but if
you find a black hole that's much more
massive than that
then stuff happened after that or some
other phenomenon went on
that would have kept accumulating kept
eating and as it eats it gets bigger and
bigger and bigger
so i don't know that you can know
precisely the age of a black hole but
you can get a sense of how long
a black hole has been been in town yeah
i i i'm gonna agree with you
i'm gonna say even more so one of the
big mysteries about the supermassive
black holes that were acknowledged
although not by name in this year's
nobel prize
was that they're so big and we
definitely know those do not form
as the end state of stellar collapse
something had to happen to make that
thing so big
so either it formed in the early
universe and this is something that's
really odd the bigger the black hole the
less
dense the material you need to make it
it's very surprising so you can make a
really big black hole out of the density
of
air under the right conditions which
really surprises people
but if you make it from a star it's got
to be incredibly dense
so it could be that it was made in the
early universe and not from stars at all
or it could be that it started as a
smaller black hole
and then went through a bunch of
collisions and and got bigger and
collected other black holes and just
amassed in a mass and a mast until it
was a supermassive black hole at the
center of the galaxy
and that requires a lot of time and a
lot of collisions
and just just to round this out
currently none of us
in in my field doubt the likelihood that
every single large galaxy has a
supermassive black hole in its core
initially it was hypothesized and then
we had some early hubble data
and then some other data and then it was
like you know this looks pretty
um endemic to what it is to be a galaxy
at all and if you have colliding
galaxies that merge
you'd expect the black holes to
ultimately merge in the middle so i got
you on that one but also
it's still i don't know i'm not that i
haven't seen the latest in this but when
i last
looked there was still some uncertainty
about whether the black hole nucleated
the formation of a galaxy
or whether the galaxy had mechanisms
that
funneled material to the center and then
make the galaxy because
even if you have a billion solar mass
black hole
which some galaxies do in their center
that is a times it's less than
one tenth of one percent of the mass of
the whole galaxy
so as ferocious as that sounds the total
galaxy wins
if you wanna if you're on a balance
absolutely so you
might have thought you know oh even if
it's true that all of these galaxies
have super massive black holes they're
such a small percentage in terms of the
mass they're probably not influential on
the galaxy who cares
but it actually turns out that's not the
case because they can blow these
gigantic winds
they could have been very active in
their early history and been like
quasars
they could have sculpted the entire
galaxy they could have regulated the
size the shape
the number of like the of stars that
formed
so they they might actually have
incredible agency despite
their smaller fraction in terms of men
and and is that because in the formation
of the black hole that
it is spewing out materials in order for
it to become what it becomes
yeah yeah in the early days it was
wreaking it was blowing out these
jets you know and it was just it was
like imagine these winds there there are
black holes whose jets are so strong
that they're puncturing neighboring
galaxies and basically wiping out any
planetary life
in those galaxies so they have
they actually just get into a fight
that's all you're not understanding the
dynamics of this
so the nobel for exoplanets is in a
fight for the nobel prize
but the point is you only get to see all
this if the if there's material in the
vicinity of a black hole for it to do
that to
right if a black hole completely ate
everything in its
vicinity then all these mechanisms shut
off there's nothing to see
right wow god that's so cool all right
all right keep it coming chuck here we
go this is liam pendergrass also from
patreon what opportunities for future
research
uh into black holes are created
as a result of this particular prize
being awarded
so is there is there anything new that
came
out of this that may spur uh
further discovery well let me lead
something here and then i'm going to
hand off to
janna because the nobel prize
is essentially always delayed from the
discovery itself
it's not clear whether the prize itself
is stimulating
more research because the original
research already did that
right so the original search was already
in we already knew it was important
we already and the the best kind of
prize is the one that
that affirms what you already knew and
in this case
this we are like janet said we knew
roger penrose was brilliant
we knew he had influential papers we
knew the
the supermassive black holes in the
centers of galaxies
that's a long-standing project so that
did trigger
other interesting projects let's look at
other galaxies to see if they have
supermassive black holes with the next
most powerful powerful telescope but
janna do you think the act of getting a
prize
itself changes any of that landscape
um gosh i i i
i think i'm with you i don't think the
act of getting the prize
does i think it might affect generations
that are just
on the rise like you know your son
chuck asked a question inspired because
we were talking about the nobel prize
and who knows maybe that's going to
affect
your son's interest ultimately in
science i mean for the scientists who
are practicing now i would say no not so
much but
but it does have that effect i think for
the younger generation
excellent point because it's it's black
holes are in the news now for a whole
other reason
yeah that that there's a celebration
with a big fat
check that's associated because in
america
money talks that's what it is i'm glad
to hear you say that because
uh that's for his research club black
holes are his
uh are his focus so uh i'm gonna i'm
gonna
ask you to ask you to talk to him
and by the way i don't care we're
totally cheating
screaming cute screw them little kids
i'll be like my son has needle grass
tyson the jet 11 i'll give a damn
sorry kids sorry
that's how the cookies crumble that's
how the cookie is
make an interesting point janet that if
it's another reason to talk about
something
in the context of it having been a
celebrated
result rather than just a highly
respected result that definitely adds a
societal force
on this i i agree with you there
entirely and it's interesting that a lot
of these nobel prizes are connected
so for instance the super massive black
hole the center of the galaxy also has
littler black holes orbiting it and and
they did form from the end state of
gravitational collapse now littler
might be 30 60 times the mass of the sun
and so ligo which is the experiment that
you mentioned earlier neil that got the
nobel prize what was it to
2016 2017 um 2017 that
they're detecting the collision of two
black holes that are more around
50 60 times the masses and each and they
might be doing that
near a supermassive black hole and so
these are all connected
discoveries and um and so some of the
ones that that ligo is beginning
to and i don't want to say observe but
really
listen to because ligo doesn't take
pictures ligo listens to the resonance
of space
around these like orbiting mallets we're
starting to think that maybe those in
fact really are coming from galactic
centers
wow so um so there could be twenty
thousand forty thousand black holes
around the center of our own galaxy
that are just smaller ones wow right
chuck we blew that whole thing well all
i can say to that is
there goes the neighborhood yeah it's
coming in
and again they're gonna destroy your
neighborhood
i'm letting you know this and they get
together
and they get bigger and they're getting
bigger
so chuck we just blew that whole segment
on your son's question oh well
totally worth it okay so when we come
back we're picking up star
cosmic queries with jan 11 we're talking
about black holes
when we return we're back start talk
cosmic queries
chuck nice with me always always
pleasure and and you're tweeting at
chuck nice comic
thank you yes i am and we're talking
black holes today so of course that
means
jan 11 is in the house and janna you're
tweeting at what
jan 11 at gen 11 and it's a janna with
two ends we got you yeah
yeah all right i i like an extra
consonant you know just in case i lose
one
in case one drops off exactly gen 11 has
three n's in it just to let the record
show
yeah that's funny
yeah what is it 40 of the letters in
your name
uh so this is cosmic queries so chuck he
keep coming at us with these questions
all
right
i'm staying with this one is from your
wife now right you're the whole family
okay
so this one is from grandma eugenio
baruno
this is eugenio barrera says
hey chuck neil janna how are you
after years of following you guys on
youtube i finally pulled the trigger
on being a patreon and i'm glad i did
because now i get my question ready
excellent yeah and he says uh
i was wondering if black holes
have the gravity gravitational pull to
affect light does it also
alter its speed
so it bends light does it slow it down
when it bends it
so interesting interesting question neil
what do you think going to try this one
i would just say no okay next question
but there's a really subtle example that
i think illustrates how bizarre it is
okay yeah right
so because the event horizon is by
definition
the place at which light cannot escape
you could ask well what happens to light
at the event horizon then if it can't
escape and so you could just
drop a little beam of light a little
bundle of light
and uh let's call it a photon and it
would sit there
at the event horizon it would not move
it's actually a completely state not
stable unstable
but a place where it can be however you
can't sit there and not move
so if you're falling across the black
hole event horizon and you fall past
that little
piece of light you go oh it's moving at
the speed of light
wow but uh nobody can say it's not
because nobody could stay there with it
because you'd have to be traveling at
the speed of light to stay there with it
so when you phone chuckles in wonderland
janet in wonderland
well the other way to think about it is
it's like a salmon
swimming up the niagara like swimming
upstream
and the waterfall of space-time is just
falling in
so rapidly that it effectively stands
still but nobody can stand still with it
everybody else is going with the
waterfall right
so everyone else if they try to measure
the speed of light it's like oh yeah
it's traveling at the speed of light
it's nearly 300 000 kilometers a second
nobody says it's standing still
but technically it's sitting right there
at the event horizon that's
but it's still trying to get out it's
still trying it's trying like hell to
get out
okay but oh that is true so what what's
the observation
outside of the black hole what are we
seeing
is it just you just never see that
photon because it never gets to you when
you say what do i see the only way you
see something is if the light hits your
eye
right so if it's stuck there because
it's stuck there
so you don't see it oh my god that's so
it's dark
yeah and about horizon's dark it's black
hole
that's crazy and another just to just to
add another point there
right you will only see that photon if
that photon enters your eye
right so therefore you have no idea it's
even there this was my issue with the
with star trek all right they have these
phasers
that no the the um phasers right when it
shoots
lasers at another ship okay those
evacuated spaces
yeah and then and then they have photon
torpedoes at full time so
they're sending this in a direction
towards the ship
but the the camera view is from the side
but you see this like you see it there's
no no it's sending this energy to the
ship there's no way you would see that
laser going to the ship right
there's just no way unless it's sending
light in your direction but that
wouldn't be an efficient weapon
yeah or you make like a gas cloud and it
scatters
oh yeah yeah yeah okay so you can make
like a fog
chamber you have to have a fog machine
you hit the
the chalkboard erasers together right
all right chuck give me some more all
right and we now know jana is a cousin
of alice in wonderland
okay this is from
this evie cool uh i
i'm gonna go with it i'm going with that
uh says what did roger penderos
do that wasn't already done by einstein
and schwarzschild before a little bit of
a hater here
a little bit of behavior so i think
hannah you you hinted to some of that
yeah but why wasn't einstein's solution
or
the sword solution inevitable what is
the different thing
that that penrose did to make it a
natural end state
well so in the simplest terms he was
able to show that generically
without assuming any special properties
like something's a perfect sphere it
could have been
an oblong kidney-shaped eggplant thing
doesn't matter
if it collapses he was able to prove it
would inevitably form
that event horizon and within that event
horizon
inevitably would be the singularity and
one way to think about this which i
think is really profound
is he was able to show that all paths of
light and this is technically one of the
ways that he did it
point towards the singularity
technically what that means
is that the singularity is in the future
we look at a black hole we think of a
spherical thing
with a center point that says point
singularity in space
what roger penrose showed is the
singularity is not in space
it's in the future once you're inside
that black hole
and so nobody who enters the black hole
can do
anything but plunge into that
singularity you can no more avoid the
singularity then you can avoid the next
moment in time
okay so wow that's good like i said
alice in wonderland there it is that's
what like i said
yeah cool you know yeah give me a second
i'm gonna go pour myself a little
vodka and we're gonna come back and talk
about this
yeah we're definitely missing some mind
altering
wow so janet we're gonna have our after
party zoom length
yeah wait so janet just to if if i
understand what you're saying
if all light beams go to the singularity
then
all all
all possible paths into your
future as you fall in would go to that
singularity because you can't take a
path
that's right so basically what it says
is if i should
it basically says if you're going slower
than the speed of light
you are definitely going into that
singularity because the only way you
could not go into that singularity is if
you went faster than the speedo light
and you can't do that right so
so the technical language would be just
because it's sometimes poetic to hear it
it's not necessarily edifying but it's
poetic
is that he proved that all of the future
light cones pointed towards the
singularity
that was what he showed there's one
figure in this paper in 1964
where he draws it all out i'm telling
you it's just the most beautiful
it's all compact it's all right there in
this one picture
where he just shows that this absolutely
is inevitable that
the black hole singularity forms and
that it is in the future
of any any path on the interior of the
black hole
yeah all all right keep it coming
okay all right uh this is izzy rohr
says hi neil chuck janna it's violetta
my mom izzy
i'm 12 years old from birmingham alabama
and i love all things astrophysical
uh professor guess says that the data
collected which ultimately proved the
existence of sagittarius a
are consistent with einstein's general
theory of relativity
while absolutely 100 not
consistent with newton's law of gravity
and even then she said that einstein is
right
at least for now my questions are how
can something a
major thing like this in the cosmos
abide by general relativity
and yet not follow one of the most basic
and fundamental laws of physics
does this mean we will need to discover
a new law of gravity and does this mean
general relativity needs to be upgraded
or expanded upon
ps janna you are the first woman
astrophysicist i ever saw in an episode
of star talk a few years back and you
have inspired me so much
ever since thank you for rocking science
so hard for girls and kids like me
all over the cosmos go jenna
thank you
thank you and and by the way
none of that question impressed me like
the way the question began
because she knew that the word data
is plural plural these data
show these data are yeah so if you know
that you're you're
you're ready for that
um well i was so flattered and flushed
that i forgot the question oh but i
think i got it okay
it's actually um i think it's if it
violates newton's laws how is that
possible
across the universe but it satisfies
einstein's laws
yeah so so i i like it this way just
because newton's laws
aren't all-encompassing doesn't mean the
laws are like
wrong they're not dead wrong and i
sometimes i sometimes try to explain it
this way if
uh if if you thought english was the
only language in the universe and then
you discovered there was this broader
concept called
language right it wouldn't make english
wrong
right english is still useful it just
has a limited range of validity
it doesn't help you with french or you
know arabic or whatever other language
it turns out that there are extensions
that's a much bigger umbrella
which is this concept of language right
so to a certain extent
in its limited range of of validity
newtonian
physics is great works terrific
it just doesn't work everywhere all the
time it's just not it's not big enough
it's not that it's
wrong it's just it's just a subset of a
larger concept
so the first thing that einstein did
when he was trying to
um test his own theory was exactly to
make sure
he he matched he respected newton that
he respected newtonian dynamic
dynamics in its range of validity which
would be
when you're not moving very quickly when
you're around big things like the earth
when
you're moving slowly like it should look
like newton said it should
so um so it's not as though when i
drop an apple and no longer does what i
used to think it does just because of
general relativity
so just so so what you're also saying
there is
that um if you take einstein's equations
and put in
low gravity and low speeds they become
newton's equations
that's right they become very close
approximations to newton's equations
yeah
exactly okay so they're still in the
same sandbox
or the sandbox is bigger now yeah yeah
the ceramics just
i mean newton never considered what
happens if i crushed the earth to a
point
or what happened if i was going near the
speed of light yeah they're stupid
and those were exactly the kind of
thoughts experiments the kind of
fantasies that led einstein to realize
that
oh newtonian mechanics would slowly look
different than we presume it is and we
would start to learn that there are
generalizations that start to look
very different in certain extreme
circumstances all right chuck we only
have like a couple of minutes left
give me okay see if we can squeeze two
in here and and janet sound bite answers
okay go
okay all right here we go cameron bishop
says singularities or regularities
i just got to know what we know about
the geometry at the center of a black
hole
yeah what's a regularity jana oh in um
a spinning black hole it turns out that
the singularity
has a different geometry than it does in
which work you'll consider which was
just kind of a perfect
implosion um but i think that for the
visitors
and wouldn't wouldn't most black holes
and police kind of brains
yes most black holes are spinning black
holes yeah okay absolutely
and when things collapse just like an
ice skater pulling in her arms
they tend to spin faster and faster so
we do believe that black holes are
likely spinning
um but but most to be honest
most astrophysicists and theoretical
physicists believe that the singularity
is is where general relativity will
break down kind of connected to your
previous question
we believe that there's another theory
that will make us understand that
singularities actually don't exist
and that they're signaling they're
telling us this isn't working
anymore like this is breaking down
it has been said the singularity is
where god is dividing by zero
which is that's a no-no no seriously
you're now going to have a cult
like write it you can't say stuff like
that
no it's going to be in queue
come to where god divides by z on
november 3rd
another one quick check give it all
right very quickly this is sam axe uh
sam says this
if you were to throw in some anti if you
were to throw some
anti-matter into a black hole would that
shrink it or make it bigger
so a lot of people have a misconception
that antimatter has negative energy or
negative mass but it doesn't there's
really
not to our knowledge anything with
negative mass so if you have an electron
its antiparticle has opposite every
other quantum number for instance if the
electrons negatively charged
the positrons positively charged but
they both have the same mass
so mass in energy is what matters when
it goes into a black hole you might
change the charge of the black hole but
you're just going to make its mass go up
it's going to get heavier okay so yeah
so antimatter is not some panacea for
for
undoing the universe and the damage that
gravity has done
right now yeah guys i think we got to
call it quits there we're out of time oh
yeah
damn always so good it's always so good
eleven
jana in the house jenna i miss you guys
i hear rumors that you're working on
another book i just
this is rumors i'm just saying i
can we bring it back yeah black hole
survival guide observe oh
we need that but we got to bring it back
for that can we bring it back
i'd love that okay we'll talk about and
and we'll be back soon i think your book
is coming out even just in a few weeks
so
all right chuck always good to have you
oh it's a pleasure janet we love you
here at star talk and thanks for always
accepting our invitations all right all
right this has been star talk cosmic
queries
the black hole nobel prize edition of
course with channel 11
and neil degrasse tyson if you're a
personal astrophysicist
keep looking up
you